20 years into the war on terror the
fight continues in countries far from
afghanistan holly williams recently got
rare access to one major hot spot she
joined yemen's military on the front
lines a civil war is underway and al
qaeda is using the country as a base for
attacks
here in yemen they're fighting a bloody
civil war but it gets so little
attention it's sometimes called the
forgotten war here's one reason why it
should matter to americans the chaos of
this conflict has helped al qaeda
survive here
yemeni soldiers took us to the front
line where they're fighting a deadly war
for control of this barren desert
these are government forces
battling rebels who've seized the
capital and swathes of land
so there's been back and forth from both
sides
these men are saying that their enemy is
about 500 yards in that direction
the saudi arabian government invited us
to witness this conflict they're backing
the yemeni government the u.s accuses
iran of arming the rebels both sides
have been accused of possible war crimes
the conflicts killed nearly a quarter of
a million people according to the un
some victims of starvation
and in the anarchy al qaeda has thrived
here the group's most dangerous
affiliate according to some despite
years of u.s drone strikes
al-qaeda's yemen branch trained the man
who attempted to down a u.s airliner on
christmas day in 2009 with explosives
sewn into his underpants and claimed
responsibility for a 2015 shooting in
paris that killed 12 and an attack in
pensacola in 2019 that left three dead
sultan alarada is the governor of
yemen's northern marrow province
what would it take to get rid of al
qaeda in yemen
we need a state he told us if we had a
functioning government we could clean
them out
more than four million yemenis have fled
their homes many ending up in dusty
camps like this one
twelve-year-old abdullah told us he
wants to be a doctor when he grows up
but as long as the war rages there's
little hope for these children's future
just the desperation that al qaeda feeds
off
the al-qaeda affiliate here in yemen
recently celebrated the taliban's
takeover of afghanistan and like other
islamic extremist groups around the
world it's been inspired by their
victory
holly williams for us in the thick of it
once again this time in yemen holly
thank you very much